[Music]
we don't know exactly what these ivory
mannequins were used for but we know
about a hundred of them still exist in
the world many of them were made in the
late 17th century and most of them are
female I'm Ann garner a curator of rare
books and manuscripts of the New York
Academy of Medicine here in New York
City today we're going to look at some
17th century ivory anatomical mannequins
that show the secrets of the human body
there's something very powerful about
handling these objects partly because
they're so mysterious what we think is
that they were probably collected as
status symbols by male physicians
there's at least one account of a woman
who was walked through the stages of her
pregnancy using one of these mannequins
if you lift up her torso immediately you
see what's inside here we have her
abdominal wall as one layer then we're
down to her intestines which also come
off and behind the intestines is the
real money shot you have a fetus and all
of these
mannequins that we know of that our
female are pregnant there's something
that feels devotional about the way that
they're positioned they all feel very
precious and almost like votive
offerings to me and by appointment you
can come visit these and see for
yourselves how delightful they are
[Music]